Allison Hanan and Jason seagull played a
couple on How I Met Your Mother for nine
seasons in that time their characters
Lily and Marshall were an example of a
partnership everyone could aspire to
however Hanigan had to put her foot down
when it came to kissing seagull while
there was no apparent animosity between
them the former Buffy the Vampire Slayer
actress revealed she simply couldn't
stand the fact that her on-screen
husband was a smoker in real life she
told Digital Spy in 2008 I cannot stand
cigarette smoke it's like kissing an
ashtray and he's trying to be polite by
having gum or mints but it doesn't help
not only is that a filthy habit but also
can I bum one it's unclear how the duo
got over hanigan's repulsion for the
remainder of the series but it's
possible they kissed a lot less than the
writers were originally intending
fortunately the actors remained on
friendly terms despite their nicotine
dust up